[موسيقى]
فيش مكان امل فيك يا
غ حرب غزه تدخل شهرها الثالث اسبوع جديد
عادت فيه مشاهد القتل
والتنكيل سعد
اخويا منذ انتهاء الهدنه الانسانيه صباح
الاول من شهر ديسمبر الحالي قتلت اسرائيل
1250 فلسطينيا في غزه في قصف هو الاسوا
منذ بدايه الحرب بحسب وصف المتحدث باسم
منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله يونيسيف جيمز
الدر ارتكب الاحتلال 77 مجزره مروعه منها
23 مجزره خلال يوم واحد اكثر المناطق التي
كانت عرضه لتلك المجازر هي مخيم جباليا
وبيت
ومستشفى كمال عدوان ومحيط مستشفى
المعمداني وكذلك في خان يونس تزامنا مع
الذكره الساب للمذبح التي شهدها هذا الحي
خلال العدوان الثلاثي وارتفع بذلك العدد
الاجمالي للشهداء منذ بدء الحرب الى
16250 شهيدا شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه ادانت
القصف الاسرائيلي الذي ادى الى استشهاد 22
فردا من عائله الزميل مؤمن الشرافي مراسل
قناه الجزيره في غزه والدي الاستاذ محمود
و وامي امينه وايضا اخي الدكتور ايمن
وزوجته الدكتوره ختام خسرت غزه هذا
الاسبوع المزيد من النخب العلميه النادره
البروفيسور سفيان تايه رئيس الجامعه
الاسلاميه في غزه وواحد من افضل 2% من
الباحثين في العالم بمجالات الفيزياء
استشهد هو واسرته بقصف على منزلهم في
منطقه الفالوجه في جباليا سعد امي وابويا
واخوات وستي وكل حب انا س اخر واحده بديش
اناكل وفي خضم هذه الحرب انقطعت غزه عن
العالم الخارجي مره اخرى بسبب مشكلات في
الانترنت والاتصالات واصبح 80% من سكانها
نازحين وفق توثيق الهيئه المستقله لحقوق
الانسان في القطاع التصعيد الدموي
للاحتلال زاد من اصرار المقاومه على
شروطها في ملف التفاوض وعلى راسها تبادل
الاسرى اذ اكدت حركه حماس ان الاحتلال لن
يحصل على اسير واحد الا بشروط المقاومه
ونجدد هنا التاكيد انه لا تفاوض ولا تبادل
الا بوقف العدوان على شعبنا وقطاع غزه
الصامد الصابر وفي ميدان المواجهه لم تحقق
اسرائيل اي نتائج ملموسه في الحرب رغم
عودتها الى سياسه المجازر
هنا يخرج جندي القسام من تحت الارض في قلب
مخيم لجنود الاحتلال ليضرب قوه مكونه من
60 جنديا في واحده من اكثر المواجهات
اثاره في هذه الحرب وبحسب الاحصائيات
الرسميه ارتفع عدد قتلى جنود الاحتلال الى
411 بينهم عشره سقطوا في يوم واحد وتؤكد
مصادر في المقاومه انسحاب 70% من قو
الاحتلال من شمال قطاع غزه تزامنا مع
اعلان الحكومه الاسرائيليه بداء الجيش
عمليه بريه شمال خان يونس جنوبي
القطاع ابرز الصحف الاسرائيليه لا تبدي
تفاؤلا من الهجوم على جنوب غزه اذ تصف
صحيفه يد عوت احرنوت عمليه خان يونس بانها
مخططه على عجل وغير مدروسه وتستبعد تحقيق
وعود نتنياهو بالنصر الكامل اما فصائل
المقاومه فترى ان عوده الحرب هي قرار
انتقامي من نتنياهو لتحقيق اهداف شخصيه
ونقول هنا بكل ثقه ويقين ان اهداف نتنياهو
وجيشه غير قابله للتحقيق باذن الله سبحانه
وتعالى وما يقوم به انما هو وصفه انتقام
وتعطش للدماء تتزايد التحديات امام المهمه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه مع اعتراف مسؤولين
في الحكومه بصعوبه اختراق الانفاق التي
يصفها المتحدث باسم الحكومه ايلون لفي
بانها فريده من نوعها في حين يقول مسؤول
اخر لصحيفه فاينانشال تايمز البريطانيه ان
تدمير انفاق غزه اشبه بالخيال العلمي ولعل
هذا ما جعل تل ابيب تبحث عن هدف جديد ضد
المقاومه لكن خارج حدود غزه فقبل ايام
نشرت صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال تقريرا يكشف
عن خطه اسرائيليه لاغتيال قاده من حركه
حماس في جميع انحاء العالم وهذا ما دفع
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وجهاز
الاستخبارات التركيه الى تحذير اسرائيل من
عواقب وخيمه اذا حاولت ملاحقه قيادات
الحركه في الاراضي التركيه وبالتوازي مع
التوترات الدوليه المصاحبه للحرب فجرت
صحيفه ها اريتس فضيحه جديده لدعايه
الاحتلال في الحرب وكذبت ما روجته تل ابيب
عن مزاعم عن قتل امراه حامل وجنينها
الملتصق بالحبل السري وقطع رؤوس اطفال
اسرائيليين وحرق جثثهم في هجوم حركه حماس
على مستوطنات غلاف غزه في السابع من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول وبحسب التحقيق الذي
اعدته الصحيفه فان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو روج هذه الاكاذيب في لقاءاته مع
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ووزير خارجيته
انثوني بلينكن وهي الذرائع نفسها التي
يكررها المسؤولون الامريكيون والاوروبي
لتبرير الجرائم الاسرائيليه المستمره حتى
[موسيقى]
اليوم